joindre au téléphone hugo houle hugo le
québécois qui a participé au 106e tour
de france est un des rares à avoir
terminé justement un des rares québécois
à avoir terminé un tour de france il est
donc on le rejoint via via skype je
crois ou facetime bonjour hugo allard
tour de france ce qui a commencé le 6
juillet dernier vous étiez 176 cycliste
a été coire 3366 km comment vous vous
sentez le ce matin après un peu de repos
je me sens bien content d'avoir fini
surtout c'est tout
tous trois ont ce même coup de pression
plus les jours à katyn et quand le vélo
c'est une magnifique mais le président
ma tête je me sens quand caroubier
france je pense quelqu'un l'adrénaline
va avoir chuté d'un demain d'avoir un
petit temps après tout ce que j'ai vécu
ou cd justement parlons-en de peut-être
cette baisse d'énergie dans les
prochains jours c'était un tour de
france particulièrement rocambolesque
il ya eu des hauts il ya eu débat
particulièrement pour votre équipe
parlez-moi de l'ensemble de la côte à
quel point ça a été une course qui était
difficile et imprévisible pour tous les
courants chauds
surtout les deux premiers jours avec mon
idole jakob fuglsang
j'avais beaucoup de pression à l'égard
des biens fonciers nous avons fait
plonger ça mon prix quand même que
l'énergie toujours bien classé présenter
les choses malheureusement est tombé à
deux reprises qu'ils ne quittent et tu
me dis je pense à la 15e étape
c'est sûr pour nous c'est un et chacun
soit le sens qu'on était venus pour
essayer d'apporter tout à fait qu'elle
m'a trop mois quant à un possible avec
lui une lecture c'est quand même une
grande déception mais après son arrivée
dans les alpes j'ai quand même bien
grimper l'école j'étais content à mon
niveau
puis ils ont été chanceux les deux
heures et après tu peux écouter on a eu
une météo difficile avec la grèce sur
une étape obligée de cassel et à la
what's app et oui pour les conditions
des almées
bien que je veux savoir la paris en un
morceau mais oui vous êtes rendus à
paris vous avez terminé au 91e et
échelon avez-vous temps prendre un petit
peu de recul et analyser un peu votre
performance individuelle est ce que vous
êtes satisfait j'ai par contre pas
d'action mais dans le jeu je peux dire
que j'ai fait un excellent tour de
france la direction d'équipés très très
fier de moi je pense qu'ils
s'attendaient pas à ce que ge a eu
autant de bonnes performances surtout en
montagne
beaucoup beaucoup progressé au niveau
antérieur
ça confirme que le travail en montagne
au pays pour moi j'ai investi beaucoup
d'efforts pour être au top niveau au
taux de 30 c'est pas facile de prendre
sa section jeux les mêmes avec la mieux
payée je suis motivé pour la suite
j'espère avoir la chance de mettre comme
objectif maintenant il faut que j'ai
fait une fois tous et bien j'ai fini
c'est bien challenge
justement vous avez participé aux trois
grands tours au tour de france le tour
d'italie le tour d'espagne
maintenant c'est quoi la suite pour vous
maintenant que fait partie de l'élite
est ce que c'est d'y demeurer aussi
passer à un niveau supérieur encore je
veux quand je pense que le meilleur est
à venir et g20 je suis moins jeunes mais
dans le vélo cinq ans j'ai encore de
belles années là le top 6 jusqu'à 32 34
j'arrive à maturité physique pour aller
chercher des performances encore
meilleures
puis après si c'est le haut niveau dans
le sens où terme des taux c'est bien que
j'aie mais j'aimerais se gagner l'étape
avec les meilleurs c'est accessible
c'est ce qui me garde toujours aussi
motivé tout les jours seulement après la
grosse apprend la discipline ma porte
faire un tour de france comme ça c'est
une longue épreuve dites-nous quand
c'est terminé ce qu'on se gâte un peu
qu'est ce qu'on mange compromis qu'est
ce qu'on fait en premier après un tour
de france cet épisode
après ça c'était une bonne soirée et que
bongo champagne mais en général on
profite de vieilles marques qu'on évite
de manger des pâtes du riz blanc qu'on a
mangé par trois semaines c'est certain
que c'est pas inscrite la prochaine
semaine
alors d'un côté vous un peu c'est bien
mérité après avoir fait ce tour de
france hugo houle merci beaucoup qu'on
va continuer de se vaut un performance à
repérer et bonrepaux dansokho au revoir
merci